– Ich habe meinen Terminplan verlegt.
Hast du ihn gesehen?
– Nein.
– Verdammt!
Egal! Ich kann weitersuchen,
während ich telefoniere.
– Achtung!
Frisch gewischt.
– Cool!
– Mhm …
– Was macht Lisa?
– Tja. Die macht wieder
alles gleichzeitig.
Die telefoniert, während
sie die Sachen zusammenpackt.
Und es stört mich auch überhaupt nicht,
dass sie hier ständig durch das
frisch gewischte Wohnzimmer rennt,
während sie telefoniert.
– Ach komm schon!
Du siehst doch, dass Lisa Stress hat.
– Bist du jetzt wieder auf ihrer Seite?
– Wir haben uns wieder vertragen, ja.
Außerdem ist Streit auch ein Stressfaktor,
und ich muss mich entspannen.
– Warum musst du dich entspannen?
– Darum!
– Heißt das, du behältst das Baby?
– Du, Nina, dein Termin beim
Frauenarzt, der ist doch um halb vier, oder?
– Ja. Aber ich kann auch
alleine hingehen.
– Das kommt gar nicht in Frage.
Ich hab’s dir doch versprochen.
Während wir beim Arzt sind,
kann ich auch noch ’n bisschen
auf meinem Laptop arbeiten.
Wir sehen uns in der Praxis, ja?
– Okay.
– Okay! Tschüss!
– Sag mal, hast du
Toilettenpapier gekauft?
– Toilettenpapier?
Das ist ... sind Stressfaktoren,
überall Stressfaktoren …